ich entwickle es gilt als eine
technologie die in den kommenden jahren
maßgeblich darüber entscheidet welche
wirtschaftsnationen künftig die nase
vorne hat um den anschluss an die usa
und china nicht zu verlieren hat die
bundesregierung eine strategie aufgelegt
das war schon im jahr 2018 jetzt wird
die fortgeschrieben und wir hören das
erste rednerin die
bundesbildungsministerin anja karliczek
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen corona hat uns
doch ein klar und deutlich gezeigt wie
groß die aufgaben sind die vor uns
liegen aber lieber opposition es ist
überhaupt kein grund schwarz zu meinen
wir sind es nämlich die mit vereinten
kräften für fortschritt sorgen denn
deutschland ist innovationsland
deutschland spielt in vielen bereichen
gerade in der grundlagenforschung in der
ersten liga münzen
das zeigt übrigens gerade die mrn
technologie sie hat es dann unserer
förderung zur marktreife geschafft auf
der ganzen welt rettet der impfstoff
mainz aus mainz gerade menschenleben und
die im emmental technologie ist eben
nicht nur ein game changer in der
pandemie sie ist auch eine riesen chance
in der krebsforschung und seit 20 jahren
haben wir dort investiert und das ist
genau das was wir als haus immer machen
wir fördern die zu fünft wir fördern
schon heute das was uns in zehn oder
zwanzig jahren wertschöpfung im
innovationsland deutschland sichert und
wir identifizieren
technologien der zukunft und treiben sie
dann durch unsere forschungsförderung
voran das bmwf steht wie kein anderes
ressort für zukunft ich habe mich dafür
eingesetzt dass wir als bundesregierung
neben dem konjunkturpaket auch ein
zukunftspaket schnüren das erhebliche
investitionen in schlüsseltechnologien
ermöglicht wir nutzen die dynamik die
die pandemie freigesetzt hat denn heute
entscheidet sich nicht nur
wie wir künftig leben wollen sondern
auch wovon für mich ist die antwort klar
wir müssen auf zukunftstechnologien
setzen auf künstliche intelligenz auf
mikroelektronik denn wenn ich in ein
auto steige dann werde ich demnächst
sagen wohin ich möchte und dann fährt
das auto allein und das verändert eben
nicht nur unseren alltag das verändert
auch unsere städte und den verkehr
und wir wollen der technik in diesen
autonom fahrenden autos unser leben
anvertrauen können so wie wir
smartphones unseren alltag von grund auf
heute verändert haben wie er die art wie
wir leben verändert haben ja die wir
arbeiten verändert haben die art wie wir
heute miteinander kommunizieren
verändert haben und genau so werden auch
die fortschritte in der künstlichen
intelligenz in der mikroelektronik bei
den quantencomputern uns ganz neue
perspektiven für die zukunft eröffnen
wie wir zum beispiel krankheiten
erkennen und heilen können wie wir die
besten produkte aus unseren maschinen
herausholen mit welchen technologien wir
das klima wirksam schützen können wir
müssen und wollen noch selbst in der
lage sein genau diese technologien zu
verstehen herzustellen und auch weltweit
zu verkaufen denn genau das ist das was
uns im grunde den wohlstand der zukunft
sichert
[Applaus]
ich will dass deutschland der große
innovationstreiber in europa wird ich
habe mir am letzten dienstag von herrn
dr külz von der firma zeiss zeigen
lassen wie entscheiden und optische
technologien und extrem ultraviolettes
licht für die mikroelektronik sind denn
mit ultraviolettem licht lassen sich die
leistungsfähigen fähigsten chips der
welt herstellen computerchips und
halbleiter sind schon heute aus unserem
alltag nicht mehr wegzudenken zu stecken
in unseren smartphones in unseren autos
in unseren computern
sie stecken in schlüsseltechnologien für
selbstfahrende autos für 5g für 6g für
das extrem ultraviolette licht
garantiert uns einen technologiesprung
denn die mikrochips werden damit
leistungsfähiger effizienter und auch
günstiger
und im moment sind nur die
niederländische firma sma mit ihren
deutschen partnern und trumpft dazu in
der lage
hochleistungsfähige und präzise
maschinen für die eu v lithografie
herzustellen
und genau hier kommt wiederum das bmbf
ins spiel
wir fördern als bundesregierung seit den
80er jahren die mikroelektronik und
arbeiten bei diesem thema ganz
mit der europäischen union zusammen und
dieses erfolgs beispiel aus der
mikroelektronik zeigt was wir für die
technologieförderung brauchen einen
langen atem
einen klugen strategischen ansatz und
immer den willen weltweit die besten zu
sein und genau diesen ansatz müssen wir
jetzt auch in anderen technologiefeldern
vorantreiben bei den quantencomputern
ist zum beispiel das rennen noch offen
und auch hier wollen wir weltspitze sein
in der grundlagenforschung gehören wir
schon lange dazu und in den nächsten
fünf jahren wollen wir einen
konkurrenzfähigen quantencomputer made
in germany baut den quantencomputer
werden auf einem kleineren raum als
mikrochips sehr viel mehr rechenleistung
konzentrieren können
die dritte schlüsseltechnologie die hier
und heute ansprechen will und auf die
wir in zukunft setzen ist die künstliche
intelligenz auch für die künstliche
intelligenz fördern wir die forschung
schon seit den 80er jahren
wir wollen eine international sichtbare
ki nation sein der attraktivste ki
forschungsstandort der welt und genau
deswegen haben wir vereinbarten bis 2025
insgesamt fünf milliarden euro allein in
die kali förderung zu stecken
bundesministerin gestatten sie eine
frage oder bemerkung des abgeordneten dr
dem ja klar
danke danke ihnen sehr moment gebraucht
weil es sich als gesetzte dabei geht es
auch vielleicht eine nummer kleiner als
immer in dem willen weltweit die nummer
eins zu sein
wenn sie das als ankündigung etwa in der
pandemie bekämpfung nehmen oder auch in
der künstlichen intelligenz leben an die
solidarische zusammenarbeit mit an
den wissenschaftlern dass am ende des
tages wie die nummer eins sein wollen
wie soll dann eine kooperation möglich
werden mit diesen general anspruch also
ich finde diesen satz sollten sie mal
semantisch intellektuell moralisch aber
vor allem ökonomisch überprüfen ob er
wirklich zum gewünschten ergebnis führt
in allen fragen immer sagt sie
die nummer eins sein zu wollen geht es
auch solidarisch lieber herr dem ich
habe gesagt dass wir genau in diesen
technologien die hier gerade genannt
habe die nummer eins sein wollen und das
ist die entscheidende frage ob wir in
zukunft unseren wohlstand noch halten
können wenn wir in technologien mit
denen wir mit unserem hohen auch arbeits
niveau überhaupt noch weltweit agieren
wollen wenn wir unseren wohlstand in
diesem land halten wollen dann müssen
wir in genau diesen stolzen
schlüsseltechnologien weltweit
wettbewerbsfähig sein und dann muss dass
sie die nummer eins sein weil die zwei
verdienten geld mehr
[Applaus]
aber genau deswegen sind genau diese
schlüsseltechnologien ein richtig
starkes investment in unsere zukunft und
am ende eben auch ganz klar die frage ob
für den wohlstand in unserem land halten
können und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich glaube wir spüren in
unseren wahlkreisen hat die
geschwindigkeit des internationalen
wettbewerbs gerade gigantisch anzieht
noch ist offen welche regionen der welt
in der entwicklung neuer technologien
den ton angibt und wer auch künftig die
technologischen und werte basierten
standards setzen und damit auch
durchsetzen kann
aber das rennen hat ganz klar begonnen
wir haben wir in deutschland und europa
eine hervorragende startposition unsere
wirtschaft und wissenschaft sind eng
verzahnt wir haben in den letzten
dreieinhalb jahren intensiv daran
gearbeitet wissenschaft und wirtschaft
immer enger zu verzahnen und das was wir
erreicht haben ist einmalig und deswegen
haben wir es jetzt selbst in der hand
aus den zwanziger jahren ein jahrzehnt
der innovation eine modernisierungs
jahrzehnt zu machen und nur so werden
wir die grundlagen für unseren wohlstand
unseres landes sichern nur so werden wir
die wertschöpfung und die arbeitsplätze
in europa halten nur so werden wir
unserer verantwortung für unsere
nachkommenden generationen in
deutschland gerecht wir brauchen jetzt
mut zur veränderung wir brauchen den mut
all diese wege mit und in kooperation um
das ganz klar zu sagen
auf der einen seite mit unseren ländern
und kommunen und im internationalen
vergleich mit der demokratischen welt
gemeinsam zu gestalten gerade beim thema
standard setzen geht es sehr klar
bereichen darum international in der
freien demokratischen welt gemeinsam
standards zu setzen
packen wir es doch einfach an
[Applaus]
das wort hat der abgeordnete dr michael
esken den neu für die auf die aktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen liebe zuschauer im
saal und bei youtube wenn wir heute über
die forschungspolitik dieser
bundesregierung ihre sogenannte carry
strategie sprechen dann sprechen wir
über die geschichte eines teuren und
epischen versagens und das ist auch
nicht zum lachen werte kollegen das
wahrsagen begann bereits mit der
ernennung von anja karliczek zur
ministerin die seit ihrer amtsübernahme
eine sache nach der anderen vergeigt wir
alle erinnern uns noch allzu gut an das
gemüse bei der wahl des standortes für
die neue batterie forschungsfabrik was
ein zufall
die wahl fiel auf münster dem
nachbarwahlkreis von frauke check der
bundesrechnungshof rückte die 500
millionen euro vergabe und frau kathi
checks cdu-kollegin eisenmann forderte
ihren rücktritt und jetzt wird die
batterie forschungsfabrik noch nicht
einmal fertig 2022 war geplant und
daraus soll jetzt 2026 werden wenn es
denn überhaupt noch irgendwas wird
diese bundesregierung hat sichtlich
keinen plan kein konzept für die zukunft
und keinerlei strategie während der
korona pandemie dürfte frau kann die
checks lange zeit friedlich vor sich hin
dieser verschlafen hat verdanken wir
dass in schulen hochschulen und
forschungseinrichtungen noch immer keine
adäquate digitale ausstattung zur
verfügung steht versagen auch beim thema
künstliche intelligenz denn da gibt es
ein ebenso simples wie schwer wieder auf
der regierungsbank kapiert ki jede
stellungnahme der politischen
entscheidungsträger dieser regierung zum
thema künstliche intelligenz strotzt nur
so vor technische inkompetenz die
vertreter dieser regierung scheitern
vermutlich schon bei der installation
von apps auf ihrem handy
und genau aus diesem grund können sie im
moment noch nicht einmal er
welches enorme potential im thema ki
steckt egal ob wirtschaft finanzen
gesundheit bildung forschung oder
landwirtschaft caae hat das potenzial
unsere gesellschaft zu revolutionieren
unsere gesundheit zu verbessern
steuergeld zu sparen und unser aller
leben einfacher zu machen und dieser
bundesregierung ist das einfach egal
schlimmer noch obwohl kaum einer es
kapiert soll die ki in deutschland schon
wieder reguliert werden zum beispiel
personalwesen
nur knapp vier prozent der unternehmen
in deutschland setzen überhaupt auf
digitale werkzeuge zur mitarbeitersuche
aber die german angst sorgt schon wieder
mal dafür dass man eine diskriminierung
durch ki fürchtet und schon mal
prophylaktisch nach dem gesetzgeber
schreibt dazu sagen wir klar nein und
leben in unserem antrag auch eine
regulierung dieses bereiches ab vollends
zufrieden wird es mit dieser regierung
wenn man sich mal die großen
versprechungen in der ki strategie
ansieht und sie mit der realität in
deutschland vergleicht dann wissen sie
was die haut voraussetzung für eine
erfolgreiche strategie ist eine sichere
stromversorgung sämtliche kg und
forschungsvorhaben haben eine sache
gemeinsam der energiebedarf steigt
erheblich denn die server und rechner
der kommenden daten wirtschaft brauchen
große mengen an strom für die grünen das
ist das was aus der steckdose kommt und
genau dieser strom wird in diesem land
immer mehr zur mangelware
stichwort atomausstieg stichwort
kohleausstieg das muss man sich mal
vorstellen die bürger sie soll zukünftig
alle mit elektro autos herumfahren und
zeitgleich steht man im
wirtschaftsministerium von peter
altmaier fest dass der strom in diesem
land nicht mehr reicht und deswegen
rationiert werden muss als wäre das
jetzt nicht schon irre genug bleibt man
eisern beim weg der energiewende ins
nichts
erst vorgestern haben sie alle
diesem haus unseren antrag abgelehnt die
energieversorgung in deutschland zu
sichern und die forschung zur
kernreaktoren der vierten generation
voranzutreiben sie sitzen ja offenbar
alle sehr gerne im dunkeln aber ich
denke dass sehen sehr sehr viele bürger
in diesem land auch anders
zusammenfassend bleibt zu sagen bei
dieser bundesregierung gilt sie führt
deutschland nicht zur spitze sondern in
den abgrund und ich denke immer mehr
bürger in diesem land erkennen dass auch
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
michael ist für die fdp fraktion hat
hierauf anja karliczek die
bundesministerin geantwortet und damit
ist denn hier jetzt ja auch die debatte
eröffnet auf michael espendiller folgt
jetzt rené röspel er spricht für die
spd-fraktion steht schon bereit
präsidentin nach dieser vorrede kommt
mir doch dass martin luther
zugeschriebene zitat in den kopf das
wohl aus einem verzagten arsch kein
fröhlicher furz kommen könne
und nach den düsteren beschreibungen
dieses landes und der welt oder
gesellschaft möchte ich jetzt nach vorne
gerichtet diskutieren und freue mich
ausdrücklich darüber dass die
bundesregierung die fortschreibung der k
s strategie vorlegt nach rund zwei
jahren
denn es sind ja in dieser zeit eine
reihe von berichten und stellungnahmen
erschienen die einzubeziehen in die
strategien sinnvoll ist die kandidatin
ethikkommission der enquete-kommission
des deutschen bundestages haben sich
intensiv wie viele andere mit
künstlicher intelligenz befasst und auch
empfehlungen ausgesprochen
das ist richtig und zeit dass eben die
bundesregierung das war ja auch von uns
als parlamentarier gefordert
eben solche erkenntnisse und
stellungnahmen auch einbezieht das ist
nicht nur als schön zu bewerten und
richtig dass der etatansatz von drei auf
fünf milliarden euro steigt das ist
wichtig aber geld ist nicht alles und
deswegen sind zwei schwerpunkte genannt
in dieser fortschreibung das wichtigste
köpfe also menschen denn künstliche
intelligenz technologie
die innovation wird es nur geben wenn
wir die menschen investieren und das
zweite technische infrastruktur und
voraussetzungen technologisch in
souveränität bin ich nicht viel zu sagen
aber das ist auch in dem weiterhin heute
diskutierten bericht zur mikroelektronik
eben auch nachzulesen reihe von
maßnahmen und ich bin aus nicht dankbar
dass die bundesregierung ab seite 22
jahren mehrere seiten beschreibt mit
spiegel blicken mit pilotprojekt und
initiativen die beschrieben werden
sollen und die an auf den tag auf den
weg gebracht werden sollen damit wir bei
künstlicher intelligenz technologien
innovationen zur handlung
außerdem würde ich sagen auch immer
fdp-antrag finden sich solche ansätze
die man mal prüfen könnte einiges ist
dadurch erledigt anderes muss ich
zugeben an dieser stelle auch nach der
debatte von vorhin nervt doch ein
bisschen wir finden es als spd
ausdrücklich richtig ich habe da schon
mal gesagt dass der bund im bereich
schule und bildung mehr verantwortung
und mehr hilfestellungen den ländern
gibt wenn aber die fdp erneut fordert
auch in diesem antrag wieder die schulen
zukunftsfähiger auszustatten
dann liegt es bei mir sehr nahe als aus
nrw stammen damit kindern in schule und
ehemals kita mal anzuschauen was die fdp
dort in verantwortung bringt und wo man
freitags abends als lehrer eltern und
schüler nicht weiß wie die schule am
montag aussehen wird also deswegen meine
bitte bevor sie mit dem finger auf
andere zeigen bitte die drei finger
berücksichtigen die auch sie selbst
zurückfallen und in dem land in dem sie
auch mit verantwortung tragen für die
vernünftige bildungspolitik zu sorgen
was in unsere zielsetzung bei künstliche
intelligenz ja alle chancen und
potentiale und möglichkeiten die diese
technologie zur verfügung stellen und
zur verfügung stellen kann zu nutzen um
bessere gesundheit pflege bedingungen
auf den weg zu bringen um mehr
energieeffizienz erreichen zu können um
im bereich umwelt und klimaschutz wieder
weitere schritte nach vorne machen zu
können ja das sind richtige maßnahme
wissen auch es gibt auch gefahren und
risiken neuer technologien mit denen wir
uns
wir müssen und deswegen finde ich
ausdrücklich richtig dass die
bundesregierung wie die koalition und
die spd eben auch gewisse maßstäbe an
neue technologien einführen und die
maßnahmen wie auch beschrieben werden
und das sind nämlich hat mich sehr
gefreut dass künstliche intelligenz zu
nutzen von menschen eingesetzt werden
soll dass wir uns nicht nur immer daran
orientieren weltspitze werden zu wollen
sondern dass wir uns an den
nachhaltigkeitszielen international
orientieren drückt das freut mich nach
den diskussionen um kate kommission wo
wir lange zeit damit verbracht haben
inwieweit kann eigentlich gemeinwohl
orientiert sein soll dass die
bundesregierung diese vorschlag
aufgenommen hat ki soll auch gemeinwohl
orientiert sein und zum nutzen der
gesellschaft und am ende freue mich auch
dass eine forderung der enquete
kommission aufgenommen werden ist die
zivilgesellschaft einzubinden und
tatsächlich macht regieren deswegen spaß
weil wir jetzt schon umsetzen können
wesentliche maßnahmen künstliche
intelligenz wird in der arbeitswelt eine
große veränderung bewirken und bei
personalauswahl in arbeitsverfahren und
ich freue mich dass die spd es
durchsetzen wird im betriebsräte
stärkung gesetz dazu hinzukriegen dass
wir in bereichen und maßnahmen der
künstlichen intelligenz die betriebsräte
mitbestimmt werden können und deswegen
ist das ein guter fortschritt danke für
diese fortschreibung und wir machen
weiter gute verantwortungs politik für
künstliche intelligenz der raspel hat
sich hier direkt an mir fdp gewandt die
ja einen antrag hier auch eingereicht
hat mit dem titel technologische
mündigkeit gewährleisten
rahmenbedingungen für kann die endungen
verbessern und auf diese kritik kann sie
jetzt auch direkt antworten mario
brandenburg ist als nächstes mit der
rede dran
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen eine redewendung besagt es sind
die kleinen dinge die zählen
ob der oder die autorin oder
urheberinnen damals an micro electro
nicht gedacht hat vermag ich nicht zu
beurteilen und trotzdem kommen aktuell
ganze industriezweige ins stottern
weil eben winzig kleine bauteile fehlen
und deswegen ist an der stelle richtig
und wichtig dass wir heute das
rahmenprogramm mikroelektronik
diskutieren doch lohnt sich dort an der
situation eben auch ein ganzheitlicher
blick 400 millionen über vier jahre das
klingt prinzipiell natürlich erst mal
nett aber wenn allein die branchenführer
aus südkorea und ich ziehe jetzt gar
nicht die china karte für das nächste
jahr investitionen von 28 milliarden
ankündige dann wirken unsere 100 starts
millionen schon ein bisschen wie ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein und liebe
bundesregierung wenn sie das so oft
gelobte ziel in dem dokument der
digitalen souveränität wirklich ernst
nehmen wird es mehr brauchen als das
bmbf dann braucht es eine abgestimmte
und gezielte europäische
kraftanstrengung den die mikroelektronik
als basistechnologie hat natürlich eine
hohe strategische bedeutung autonomes
fahren die hier so oft angesprochene
künstliche intelligenz robotik ich
brauche nicht alles aufzuzählen
und es ist auch klar wenn wir an dieser
stelle versagen oder abhängigkeiten
geraten brauchen wir keine ki strategien
mehr aufstellen und auch keine ki
observatorien einrichten ohne hardware
keine software und im letzten
rahmenprogramm mikroelektronik war
übrigens marktanteil auch noch eines
ihrer ziele
da hat sie aber leider die realität
eingeholt denn bei komplexen logischen
schaltungen und speichertechnologien
spielt europa leider fast keine rolle
mehr
waren wir vor jahren noch bei 10 prozent
marktanteil sind wir jetzt bei
halbleiter fertigungs ausrüstungen ganz
europa bei einer quote unter fünf
prozent und aus dem technologischen
wettbewerb zwischen europa den usa und
asien ist leider ein zweikampf geworden
und da muss man schon ansprechen dass
sie liebe bundesregierung aber auch die
eu geräuschlos den verkauf des
chipherstellers a m
zustimmen obwohl der neutrale
europäische technologie
anbieter für einen guten ausgleich im
globalen wettbewerb gesorgt hat und das
in einer zeit als ex-präsident rampl
handelskrieg ausrief china bzw peking
ganz massiv in die halbleiter investiert
und ja natürlich brauchen wir
forschungen aber ich sage auch wir
brauchen eindeutig mehr mut mehr markt
eine entschlossenere wirtschaftspolitik
und am besten ohne herrn altmaier und
deswegen loccum sie bitte ausländische
hersteller nach deutschland um hier
werke zu bauen um das wissen zirkulieren
zu lassen um darum start-up ökosysteme
wachsen zu lassen
ermöglichen sie investitionsbedingungen
die hier einen vitalen markt schaffen
und vor allem ermöglichen sie wieder
produkte made in europe auch im check
und prozessor design
denn eins ist klar der staat muss
endlich aufhören alles selbst nachbauen
zu wollen
aggressives standortmarketing statt
politischer produktionshallen für chips
wasserstoff und batterien denn weder hat
der staat die kompetenz noch das geld im
internationalen technik wettbewerb
mitzuhalten vielen dank soweit im mario
brandenburg auf ihn folgt jetzt petra
sitte sie ist für die linksfraktion die
sprecherin für forschungs- technologie-
und innovationspolitik das noch kurz
warten nun dass ihr pult des infiziert
wurde und nun kann sie aber sprechen
meine damen und herren
vor zweieinhalb jahren hat rené röspel
schon recht ist die erste ki strategie
der bundesregierung vorgelegt wurden vor
anderthalb jahren hat die daten
ethikkommission ihr gutachten geliefert
und vor einem halben jahr hat die am
kennt kommission künstliche intelligenz
ihren bericht vorgelegt also man könnte
meinen ist genügend da um darauf
aufzubauen und da unterscheiden wir uns
nämlich genau das hat die
bundesregierung bei dieser überarbeitet
und strategie eben nicht getan
ich will hier nur an meine forderung
oder an unsere forderungen zu mehr
gemeinwohlorientierung erinnern über
eine überschrift ist dieses thema in
dieser neuen strategie überhaupt nicht
hinausgekommen
aber ich will auch sagen dass mich das
jetzt nicht so sehr überrascht
aber was mich wirklich überrascht hat
ist die völlige abwesenheit konkrete
vorschläge zur regulierung und ich halte
das für einen kapitalen fehler sowohl
die daten ethikkommission als eben auch
die enquete-kommission haben konkrete
handlungsempfehlungen zu diesen fragen
vorgelegt zu denen hätte sich die
bundesregierung verhalten können und
müssen
tut sie aber nicht stattdessen wären
also allgemeinplätze über ordnungsrahmen
und sowas verbreitet ist es vollkommen
unverständlich
nun könnte man ja sagen okay sie wollen
sich noch ein bisschen bedeckt halten
weil es ja jetzt auch um die diskussion
des europäischen ordnungsrahmens geht
kann sein dass sie das tun wollen halte
ich aber auch für falsch gerade jetzt
müssten offensiv ideen vorgestellt
werden und aufgegriffen werden und wenn
sie in wenn man in ihrer logik denkt
dass wir da die nummer eins werden
wollen was auch immer dann wäre das ja
genau der richtige punkt tun sie aber
nicht
so haben wir in der projektgruppe medien
beispielsweise konkrete
handlungsempfehlungen für plattformen
regulierungen erarbeitet ich darf daher
in
an algorithmische transparenz ich darf
an unsere empfehlungen zum micro tage
ding also zu personalisierten
botschaften an besonders kleine zu
zielgruppen erinnern
und ich darf auch daran erinnern dass
wir empfehlungen gegeben haben zum
zugriff auf daten von plattformen zu
forschungszwecken nichts davon über all
das wird ja auf europäischer ebene mit
dem digital service act diskutiert und
wie sie sich dort einbringen erfahren
wir jedenfalls nicht über diese
strategie
das wäre aber notwendig weil das gehört
nämlich hier mitten in die debatte
hinein kann aber auch sein dass sie
wirklich noch im dunklen tappen würde
mich jetzt nicht wundern man liest viel
von vertrauenswürdiger kari man liest
viel von vertrauenswürdiger elektronik
aber wenn es dann konkret wird fragt man
sich so einen guten ansatz wie garics
mit der ja vertrauenswürdige europäische
daten infrastruktur geschaffen werden
soll wird begleitet von unternehmen wie
palandt hier die sitzen dort regelmäßig
am tisch und was macht dieses
unternehmen dieses unternehmen
verarbeitet große datenmengen für
nachrichtendienste würde ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt als erste vertrauensbildende
maßnahme einschätzen und wieso setzt man
explizit auf die agentur für innovation
und cyber sicherheit auch diese
entwickelt für militärische zwecke für
offensive einsätze auch das macht in die
ansätze für andere anwender in der
wirtschaft mich unbedingt an die an der
erster stelle
vertrauenswürdig also klären sie unsere
letzte empfehlung aus dieser rede
zwischen angriff und schutz endlich was
sie darunter verstehen
ansonsten können sie hier nicht
vertrauenswürdig über vertrauenswürdige
technik reden dankeschön
in cannes und deutschland in
mikroelektronik zu den führenden
forschern oder entwicklern und
herstellern werden darüber diskutiert
der deutsche bundestag unter anderem ist
das rahmenprogramm der bundesregierung
für forschung und innovation 20 21 bis
24 hier thema und nächste rednerin ist
anna christmann für die grünen
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe frau ministerin zum
wiederholten mal hören wir heute von
ihnen das alles fantastisch vorangeht
das entspricht allerdings leider nicht
der wahrnehmung die viele von uns in
diesem land haben denn die förderung des
bundes sind in vielen fällen viel zu
kleinteilig und viel zu langsam
es fehlt schmerzlich an versprochenen
wuchs in der umsetzung den wir zur
bewältigung der großen krisen wie klima
und kann dem nie brauchen und liebe frau
ministerin es ist doch nicht ihr job
jetzt überall gute laune zu verbreiten
sondern ihr job ist mit inbrunst für die
wissenschaft zu streiten und das haben
sich offenkundig in den letzten jahren
nicht ausreichend getan denn die ki
strategie die heute so beschworen wird
ist ja schon jetzt im grunde gescheitert
denn sie reden immer von den fünf
milliarden strebt dafür bräuchten wir
aber 500 millionen pro jahr die
ausgegeben werden müssten im letzten
jahr waren das 137 millionen
das heißt es bräuchte 35 jahre bis wir
bei den fünf milliarden ankommen das
kann doch wirklich ernst sein und dass
wir die technik
wir brauchen für die bekämpfung von
klimakrise bessere gesundheit et cetera
ist hier vielfach gesagt worden das ist
uns als grüne auch sehr klar denn wir
haben deswegen eine grüne ki strategie
vorgelegt bei der wir vor allem auf ein
starkes europa setzen wir wollen
europäische forschungsnetzwerk mit der
wirtschaft gemeinsam fördern und das ist
bitter nötig diese europäische
perspektive und die haben das ja auch
ein stück weit von uns übernommen sagen
jetzt auch immer ki made in europe
aber sie tut eben nichts dafür die
einzige förderung für gemeinsame
projekte war eine ausschreibung mit
frankreich zusammen da ging es genau um
5 millionen dem standen 150
projektanträge gegenüber das ist nicht
die made in jork das ist lächerlich was
zu begrüßen ist dass es jetzt die
agentur für spruch innovationen gibt und
das ist uns auch wichtig aber auch da
bisher sind gerade mal zwei millionen
für projekte gefördert geschlossen
und warum weil sie nicht genug freiraum
geben und das wird auch immer wieder
kritisiert dort werden andere
fördermöglichkeiten notwendig als so
einschränkende geschichten die nur 100
prozentige tochter des bundes das ist
unattraktiv deswegen funktioniert es
nicht und deswegen sind wir für mehr
freiraum für die agentur für sprung
innovationen
daneben schlagen wir aber auch nach
vorne gewandt eine neue
innovationsagentur vor wir wollen eine
die nova gründen die hochschulen und
mittelstand auch stärker zusammen bringt
denn wir müssen doch alle wie sie ideen
von denen sie heute auch wieder
gesprochen haben sein
mission freien fahrzeuge sei es die in
der medizin unverträglichkeit zwischen
medikamenten zum beispiel entdeckt das
müssen wir doch in die praxis bringen
dafür brauchen wir mehr kooperation
zwischen wissenschaft und wirtschaft
dafür legen wir konkrete ideen vor
wir brauchen kein schönreden dessen das
alles schon wunderbar laufen sondern wir
brauchen mehr einsatz und beste
bedingungen für die menschen die an den
ideen arbeiten die wir in die umsetzung
bringen müssen und dafür machen wir sehr
klare vorschläge machen sie sich daran
anna christmann war dass die sprecherin
für innovations- und technologiepolitik
von bündnis 90/die grünen und damit
kommen wir schon zur letzten rednerin in
dieser debatte zur künstlichen
intelligenz strategie der
bundesregierung das ist albern kopfsatz
emre sie sitzt für die spd fraktion
unter anderem in der enquetekommission
künstliche intelligenz die sich auch mit
der gesetz gesellschaftlichen
verantwortung für ebendiese beschäftigt
die bundesregierung betont in der
fortschreibung der keine strategie den
regulierungsbedarf für künstliche
intelligenz und deshalb ist das sehr
passend dass in dieser woche der
regulierungs vorschlag der eu öffentlich
wurde
was wird ja allerdings in teilen
dürfen stand heute ist ziemlich zahnlos
inkonsequent und in weiten teilen
gefährlich hochrisiko anwendungen müssen
demnach eine konformitätsprüfung von
dritten bestehen so weit so gut
in vielen fällen jedoch reicht dafür
eine selbstauskunft der hersteller so
ist das zum beispiel bei der
lernsoftware zur überprüfung der
kreditwürdigkeit beim kritik des
policing im asylverfahren und auch zur
unterstützung der rechtsprechung und da
sag ich das ist ziemlich krass darüber
hinaus wird eine allgemeine überwachung
von crm-systemen zwar erst einmal
verboten es sei denn öffentliche stellen
halten es für nötig und da sage ich dass
es mehr als krass das ist gefährlich und
viele verstehen die diskussion noch
nicht sogar der berliner zoo macht sich
auf den weg und will durch
gesichtserkennung warteschlange ersparen
wieso nicht klingt ja erst mal praktisch
aber nein verdammt noch mal zum
mitschreiben biometrische
gesichtserkennung ist grundrechts
feindlich es kommt nicht darauf an wer
sie einsetzt wir geben damit so oder so
wieder ein stück privat hat privatheit
und selbstbestimmung auf und deshalb
kann ich an dieser stelle nur erneut die
k an cat sondervoten der spd fraktion
zur lektüre empfehlen für die einstufung
von brauchen wir einen differenzierten
risikobasierten ansatz wie auch die
daten ethikkommission schon
vorgeschlagen hat und dabei zeigt die
datenschutz grund verordnung schon den
weg auf ausgehend von den zwecken einer
datenverarbeitung werden risiken
identifiziert angemessene maßnahmen
abgeleitet und schon beim entwickeln
implementiert die instrumente dafür
haben wir das nennt sich data protection
und data security by design und verdammt
nochmal datenschutz ist kein heimchen
verantwortungsvolle technologiepolitik
schütz bürgerinnen und bürger vor
potenziellen missbrauch
die datenschutz grund verordnung ist
dabei das versprechen dass technologie
unsere werte der analogen welt
beinhaltet
und wer diesen nicht genügt und das gilt
auch aus aktuellem anlass für zum
beispiel wie luca app darf eben nicht
zugelassen werden
und wer sich dann noch mehrfach falsch
äußert oder billigend sicherheitslücken
in kauf nimmt sollte auch nicht mit
steuermitteln unterstützt werden
vertrauen allein etwa die
selbstverpflichtung von herstellern
macht am ende keine gute technologie und
das gilt auch gerade für keinen der
gesetzgeber macht die vorgaben nicht die
technologie und auch keinen rapper
vielen dank
[Applaus]